I'm desperate for people to start
defining their hopes and dreams and
wants and needs on their terms not on
what I say I don't care if you want to
hustle 18 hours a day I really don't I
really really don't I don't care if you
want to buy the New York Jets I don't
care what you want or need you need to
care about what you wanted you can't
worry about what I'm saying you can't
worry about whoever your flavor of the
month is right maybe on your flavor of
the month like maybe maybe maybe a
consistent flavor of the life is your
mom's point of view is your older
brother who's gotta do with good wisdom
but wants you to be a lawyer but you
don't want to be a lawyer you want to be
a street artist you wanna you want to
take the chance of being an entrepreneur
or the reverse or the reverse I know
peaches and loves entrepreneurship more
than me but I think is you see me all
the time talking about like
self-awareness are you one this is the
golden era for entrepreneurship people
ask me for selfies this will go away it
may not go away from me but it's gonna
go away
like you know it's entrepreneurship like
a rap artist like a baseball player like
the heavyweight nobody cares who the
heavyweight champion of the world is
right now
nobody cares who's an active astronaut
but they surely did in 1969 and 1954 for
a heavyweight champ or you know they
change they change and it will always
change and it will continuously change
and right now entrepreneurship is in
this pedestal that's having its moment
and what I'm fearful of is
you watch my videos you see my Instagram
quotes and what I want to clarify for
everybody is I hope you understand I am
NOT giving advice to everybody the only
advice I'd like to give to everybody is
to do you define what your North Star is
to understand yourself to understand
what your work-life balance
ambitions are how much what your
financial ambitions are what your life
challenges are the problems that you
want to try to solve and cure as we all
do as humans trying to climb those
different mountains in our lives
what makes you tick that is all that
matters don't do that you know I don't
think daily be or all these videos for
you to be like me I don't think anybody
should be like maybe boy under enormous
amounts of pressures and sacrifices that
I recognize are just not healthy or
valuable to anybody else but it's also
not healthy or valuable to me to do some
of the things that you want me to do
like it's not fun for me to work 9:00 to
5:00 like I will break I will be is
equally devastated as you would be to
work till midnight every day and so we
just need a call to action for everybody
recognize we have to stop judging
everybody else I'm not judging you I'm
creating content for you to use as a
barometer to try to figure out what you
like and what you don't like and I'm
trying to provide value
my actions and my content to bring two
people to amplify their worlds and
that's really it that's the
clarification like I I don't want people
to to be like me I don't want people to
do eight I want people to do themselves
and they just have to start with
understanding themselves and not trying
to be like me in this moment that person
the next moment that person next moment
the people that most win or in tune with
themselves and figure themselves
you